los miles de migrantes varados en
colombia en chile o en méxico muchos de
ellos con destino eeuu el miércoles el
secretario de estado de eeuu anthony
blinken se reunió con el presidente de
colombia iván duque en bogotá tras la
reunión blinken ahondó en la necesidad
de un trabajo conjunto en toda la región
para paliar esta situación
debemos tener un enfoque regional
coordinado con responsabilidad
compartida ninguno de nuestros países
puede abordar este desafío actuando solo
y ese es el principio detrás de lo que
estamos haciendo esta tarde y lo que
estaremos haciendo en el futuro join a
confort la reunión bilateral dio paso a
una conferencia de ministros venidos de
diferentes países de la región
implicados en las crisis migratorias a
los migrantes varados en necoclí cerca
de la frontera colombiana con panamá las
palabras de los políticos les suenan muy
lejanas creo en la ronda política porque
terminan
dando promesas que no se cumplen
esperemos que en esta hay una respuesta
favorable
las autoridades de necoclí estimaron
recientemente que en torno a 15.000
migrantes en su mayoría haitianos
esperan a cruzar en lancha hacia la
selva de darién en panamá un paso temido
en su camino hacia eeuu se estima que al
menos 90.000 personas habrían intentado
cruzar esta selva en 2021 una cifra
estimada de ellos perecieron esperando
una respuesta de los gobiernos de la
región